ich hab so einen ganz alten mail-account
da habe ich vor einem monat um alle
mails raus gelöscht weil ich schon
manchmal auch noch mails bekomme da die
ich brauche ja wir haben jetzt schon
wieder 2152 mails ich bin gott hier im
spam ordner und ich bekomme da so
unfassbar fackel viel werbung und
spam-mails mit irgendwelchen artikeln
irgendwo im internet die ich kaufen soll
und ich habe mir gedacht eigentlich ganz
interessant bestellt sein doch mal ein
zwei tage lang alle spam mails und das
habe ich gemacht ich bin fertig habe ich
noch gar nicht begrüßt das irgendwie
nachträglich leute ich zeige euch hier
mal kurz mein postfach vielleicht muss
ich ein bisschen was zensieren weil das
steht auch manchmal mein name oder der
von meinem vater der wtf ich weiß echt
nicht ihr könnt euch das hier geben guck
mal 412 newsletter und wie gesagt das
ist noch nicht lange her da habe ich das
alles mal gelöscht als sie das sind ja
so viele mails alter das sind ja so
viele newsletter wo ich mich angemeldet
habe und dann haben wir hier natürlich
auch noch spam over here hier soll ich
einen kaffeevollautomaten bestellen oder
auch 50 euro rabatt plus weniger reste
bei hello fresh das sind glaube ich so
ist so ein essens liefern dann kannst du
selber ein essen kochen könnte man auch
mal bestellen oder jetzt neu 15 euro
erst mal nicht doppelt angebote sichern
bei mona oder die auch sehr geile sachen
die es hören einem good day ließ lisa
vom chongqing tschechow oder das bestell
ich direkt mal
es werden die nächsten tage steak auch
noch einige spam-mails ankommt sonst ich
habe auch noch ein zweites postfach und
da bestelle ich jetzt einfach mal das
video zieht sie auf jeden fall über ein
längeren zeitraum wir haben heute jetzt
in 24 05 und wir sehen uns ich habe auf
jeden fall in den letzten tagen immer
mal wieder in mein postfach geguckt und
so einiges bestellt wie war nicht dabei
weswegen ich auch noch weiter nach unten
vom datum mehr in mein postfach gegangen
bin und dort auch noch sachen bestellt
habe insgesamt habe ich acht sachen
bestellt für über 200 euro einige fehlen
noch aber das meiste ist eigentlich
ankommt und das schauen wir uns jetzt
mal zusammen an vorher habe ich aber
noch eine cola empfehlung für euch und
das ist egal leute wenn ich mal ganz
kurz dazwischen grätschen darf das
heutige video wird mal wieder
unterstützt von igraal was egal ist und
warum das ganze für euch auch bestimmt
interessant ist erkläre ich euch mal
kurz also volle aufmerksamkeit igraal
ist eine website app und
browsererweiterung mit der man beim
online shoppen ganz einfach geld
zurückbekommt mittlerweile findet ihr
bei igraal rund 1800 partnershops aus
ganz vielen kategorien mode elektronik
und so weiter und so fort also safe in
ihr ist gerade dieses video schaut euch
eben noch gedacht kauf ich das oder
kaufe ich das nicht bei der und der
seite oder der und dem shop gibt es auf
jeden fall bei igraal checkt das mal ab
um zu verstehen wie das läuft zeige ich
euch einfach mal und zwar sind wir hier
auf ran.de davor dann landet ihr auf der
deutschen seite wir lagen uns mal ein
ich kann hier als alex fortfahren ganz
entspannt und facebook und ich habe
sogar von einem meiner letzten käufe 9
eur 52 hier noch als guthaben wenn ihr
20 euro erreicht habt könnt ihr euch das
ganz entspannt auf euer bankkonto
auszahlen lassen und wir scrollen mal
hier durch new media markt/saturn lenovo
tomorrow es gibt wirklich alles möglich
sogar urlaub ihr könnt urlaub buchen und
bekommt geld zurück wie geil ist das
denn es könnte im urlaub wieder raus
hauen da ist im heutigen video um spam e
mails geht und ich weiß dass ich von
vertu auch öfter mal eine bekomme kaufen
wir einfach mal was bei bauten cashback
aktivieren und wir kommen direkt zur
baut yu weiter zum shop letzte auf
diesen wurde hier habe ich gestern bei
einem kollegen von mir gesehen und der
sei echt nice aus deswegen kaufe ich mir
dann einfach mal der holy ist sogar
schon runter gesetzt wir sparen 15 euro
und ich kriege noch was wieder besser
kann es sich eigentlich nicht laufen ich
habe jetzt alles ein geben konnte meine
kreditkarte hier angeben ganz entspannt
bezahlen ich habe jetzt 29 euro 90
bezahlt - nochmal zehn prozent ich
zurück bekommen also genannten bei circa
27 euro da kannst du wirklich nicht mehr
kaputt euch auf jeden fall die app aus
dem appstore oder place tor
meldet euch an dann bekommt ihr 10 euro
hier über meinen link als startguthaben
bei mir bei uns jetzt hier nur fünf ich
habe dann allerdings auch noch eine
bestellung bei elsers getätigt und hatte
kurze zeit später hat dann das cashback
auf meinem konto gutgeschrieben und wie
gesagt ab 20 euro könnt ihr es euch
auszahlen lassen auf ein paypal konto
oder euer bankkonto wie ihr wollt in
brüssel ganzen habt ihr ja gar nichts zu
verlieren außer bisschen speck
zurückzubekommen leute das ist doch
einfach kinderleicht checkt egal ab
nutzt das und wir machen jetzt weiter
mit dem video das ist wieder genau diese
jahreszeit wo ich so toll diesen
schnupfen krieg gegen polen ihr seht bis
jetzt eher magere ausbeute ich habe
insgesamt acht sachen bestellt vier sind
schon da zwei kommen morgen die anderen
das dauert noch zwei wochen also ich
weiß auch nicht sie kommen irgendwo aus
china oder keinen plan aber der start
heute schon mal mit diesem 4 sagen ich
würde sagen lag skoda
ich bin wirklich gespannt ich weiß
natürlich ungefähr worum es geht ich
meinen tag hier alles aus meinem
email-postfach bestellt und dort schon
mal gesehen
zum teil sind wirklich sehr verrückte
sein weil auch das was morgen noch kommt
das weiß ich gar nicht so ganz genau was
das war
starten wir doch einfach mal hier wird
das kann ich auch ganz einfach aufreißen
das kommt aus und man bekommt das keine
ahnung
stell dich mal drauf was haben wir denn
hier
boxershorts baumwolle herren retro
shorts und 1000 print hat sogar nur 6
eur 990 gekostet also insgesamt für alle
sachen habe ich über 200 euro ausgegeben
das hier ist dann jetzt anscheinend ihr
unterhose muss ich sagen unterhosen als
nur einige scheiße jaja etf also selber
erklärt euch wen also ich hab es nicht
aber schnell durch das vor und dann
kommt halt darauf an zeichner und dann
hast du so eine unterhose mit fakt ist
es einfacher sind das über verden gut
die kann ich jetzt nicht gleich
anprobieren sieht auf jeden fall ultra
verrückt aus ich meine das wäre so
gewesen bei dieser seite man konnte eine
unterhose bestellen und bekommst du
zufällige zugeschickt hat mir so was
jetzt sieben euro wert ist weiß ich
nicht aber ich werde sie auf jeden fall
mal anprobieren junge ach du scheiße
weitergeht
das nächste paket man kann hier schon
leicht durchschauen und da bin ich jetzt
mal gespannt was ich hier passiert und
auch das geil ist also das hier ist von
super series hier unten steht nach drauf
er weist service at gmail.com die haben
nicht mal eine info mail oder so ich
habe wirklich absolut kein planen sie so
was wie lange so etwas in meinem bett
ordner oder newsletter von meinem
e-mail-account den ich seit acht jahren
habe keine ahnung was ich früher damit
getrieben habe guck mal hier sogar mit
ist das eine maske er hört dass wir hier
schon sehen auf der verpackung
schutzraum und hier steht auch drauf wie
es gemacht wird also das muss ich auf
jeden fall irgendwo dranhängen und
so kann ich mich mein kopf darlegen
warum braucht man so was noch so
irgendwo rum es ist halt nur die frage
wo soll man denn so etwas festmachen ich
meine wenn man jetzt unterwegs ist am
strand kiek du kannst das niveau fest
machen vielleicht an einem sonnenschirm
aber er hält das ja nicht na ja eben was
wären wir schon einfallen
wir schauen uns das jetzt mal genauer
leute wir benutzt jetzt einfach mal
meinen kleiderständer hier hatte man
kann das hier verstehen das ist ganz gut
jetzt hängt das ding hier halt okay wir
lehnen uns ganz wie sie zurück und
schont sie kann man sich hier ein harten
einhängen und mega okay ich habe
irgendwie angst dass das gleiche da oben
weg fliegt und mein kopf auf den boden
knallt also ok unbequem ist es nicht ich
entspanne jetzt einfach mal kurz zu
minute und dann gebe ich euch ein
kleines fazit also den sinn davon checke
ich halt wirklich nicht ihr könnt ihr
mir eure vermutung in die kommentare
schreiben
das ding ab 25 euro gekostet ich weiß
nicht also bis jetzt würde ich
eigentlich eher sagen klopp es sei denn
man findet ihn richtig gute
anwendungsbereich dafür aber da kann ich
meinen kopf auch viel besser auf dem
kopfkissen legen hast du den gleichen
effekt also dass es bis jetzt auf jeden
fall das dümmste produkt weiter geht es
mit dem dritten paket das könnte auch da
irgendwas zum anziehen rein und hab ich
noch mal unter großem gestellt aber ich
kann mich schon gar nicht mehr so ganz
genau daran erinnern
wir haben hier einfach mal joana planz
mich auf den unterhosen aus also
unterhose oder kleidungs newsletters
base land sehr viel in meinem postfach
das habe ich gemerkt und vor allem
anscheinend unter moosen nur hier muss
man wirklich sagen kann wir haben ja
einst alter 2345 unterhosen für 13 euro
99 habe ich dafür
also da kann man wirklich nicht mehr
kann und ich meine alle in verschiedenen
farben größe ja die größe sollte mir
passen
qualität wird alles gut also das ist mal
ein guter kauf nicht immer diese scheiss
langweiligen calvin klein dinger in
denen jeder snapshot news verschicker
rumläuft nee ich trage was nicht ich
trage hier die marihuana boxershorts von
diana maria wer kennt nicht die marke
ganz bekannt auch in deutschland so die
finde ich auf jeden fall deutlich
schöner als die einhorn oder
führerschein ich weiß es noch nicht
leute ich bin gekommen mein büro und wir
haben ein neues paket ich glaube das ist
nur in china kam
hier haben wir den heil und heilung
keyboard ihrem es neben ok das ist
wahrscheinlich auch ein bisschen
langweilig aber es hat 40 euro kostet
die wundern sich wahrscheinlich auch das
wirklich leute über die email über
dieses geld kaufte ich war
wahrscheinlich der einzige bis jetzt
haben wir das hätte ich wirklich nicht
bestellen müssen also es ist jetzt eben
ein bisschen los ist was gegen erkältung
du kannst du warmes wasser einfüllen und
dann so ein bisschen in halle wo ich
weiß nicht ob ich das jetzt unbedingt
ausprobieren und ein paar sekunden
später und wie china kuba mit
kaffeegeschmack bisschen kaffee ränge
macht er das glaubt mir keiner ich hatte
hier in meinem büro kein warmes wasser
aber ich hab noch warmen kaffee war ich
bin halt gerade das ist morgens ich habe
gerade das war das erste was ich heute
gemacht habe
wir machen einfach schnell weiter mit
dem nächsten zug kommen zum nächsten
teil das ja glaube ich 70 euro und
kostet also ist auch schon ein bisschen
risikoreich und das ist hier kommt die
konfi aber das ist ja ganz schön hoch
verpackt da bin ich mal gespannt ob das
70 euro wert okay das ist so ein riesen
pulli zum chillen anscheinend eigentlich
nur also frauen sind hier auf dem
aber ich habe es anscheinend trotzdem
bestellt falls ja was das denn so
hochwertig auf jeden fall gestaltet muss
ich sagen die verpackung man hat hier
direkt man kann direkt die habe von dem
kopf
ich bin hier ausgewählt hat ich hab's
hellblauen haben oder so babyblau also
die qualität ist nur diese eigentlich
nicht schlecht wie groß ist das ding das
problem ist halt wir haben gerade
draußen gefühlt 30 grad ich bin so ins
schwitzen den ganzen tag schon für den
sommer ist das nix mehr im winter
entspannt auf dem sofa kuscheln damit
okay ich würde das jetzt eigentlich das
wahlalter selbst privaten aus dem report
genau zu erkennen
das ist auf jeden fall echt ein leichtes
teil du kannst ja auch deine sachen drin
verstauen hast du mit bauchtasche auf
ganz locker lässig und dann kann man
sich auch sofort spielen oder leute ich
sag mal so früher wäre das auf jeden
fall im vip klub auch cooles gadget
gewesen und ein bisschen die ladies zu
beeindrucken
lehrer ohne scheiß hier so im winter hat
zum abhänge auf dem sofa eigentlich
gleich schlecht also daumen nach oben
von mir für dieses geile produkt danke
dass diese special teil in meinem
postfach gelandet ist und jetzt sieht es
auch hinaus soll es scheiße machen und
damit nochmal nachträglich hier aus dem
schnitt ich habe auch kein ende gemacht
deswegen macht das hier noch ich hoffe
das video hat euch gefallen wenn die
anderen sachen anfang an gesagt macht
noch ein paar wobei ich muss auch ganz
ehrlich sagen es waren halt nicht so
geile sachen dabei weswegen sich das
glaube ich nicht lohnt aber ich hab's
mal ausprobiert und an sich fand ich die
video der auch ganz cool ich hoffe euch
allezeit trotzdem gefallen und wir sehen
uns wird dort gibt's neues video
abonnieren super g an den kanal nach
oben drei leute